and back to that thought though another
second maybe off the clock got a foul
widely found Jackson for the tie why
didn't they foul 1.1 to play am I
missing something here
what a gift
the pelicans have to bring it in there's
no timeouts left guys let's play
titoo 136 we're going to double overtime
Alfred Payton acid joke Ronnie and those
guys who sit on the floor there's no
timeouts supposedly
[Applause]
how do they call the timeout we'll get
an explanation I think it's a technical
foul
[Music]
now is it a tactical
so then why are they giving them the
timeout if they play they're discussing
it now they were both teams are out of
timeouts this confusion obviously among
the three that we're looking at right
now hey listen listen to this
if Phoenix now gets a free throw because
that's a technical and they didn't get
the foul what a horrible way so they are
getting too technical here oh my
goodness yeah what a way to lose Chris
Webber you remember that that's way back
when